>> Tucker: WELL, WHEN
WASHINGTON BAILED OUT THE
FINANCE WORLD MORE THAN A DECADE
AGO AFTER THE MOST RECENT
FINANCIAL COLLAPSE, THE
GOVERNMENT SENT LIMITS ON CEO
COMPENSATION AND THEY DID IT FOR
A REASON.
TAXPAYER BAILOUTS SHOULD BE USED
SAVING JOBS, NOT MAKING
CORPORATE EXECUTIVES RICHER THAN
THEY ALREADY ARE.
SO IT’S STRIKING BY CONTRAST TO
SEE THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION,
WHICH BEGAN DISHING OUT
$14 BILLION IN BAILOUT FUNDS FOR
AMERICAN UNIVERSITIES THIS MONTH
IS NOT SETTING SIMILAR LIMITS ON
HOW MUCH UNIVERSITY PRESIDENTS
GET TO PAY THEMSELVES.
AND THEY PAY THEMSELVES MORE
THAN YOU MIGHT THINK.
A LOT.
COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY, FOR EXAMPLE
IS GETTING $12.8 MILLION IN
BAILOUT MONEY DESPITE HAVING AN
$11 BILLION ENDOWMENT.
THE PRESIDENT OF THAT SCHOOL,
PERSON CALLED LEE BULLINGER
MAKES MORE THAN $2 MILLION A
YEAR.
IN OTHER WORDS, LEE BULLINGER
ET CETERA COLLECT ABOUT
ONE-SIXTH OF THE ENTIRE FEDERAL
BAILOUT.
RENSSELAER POLYTECHNIC
INSTITUTE, SCHOOLEY PROBABLY
HAVEN’T HEARD OF AND PROBABLY
FOR GOOD REASON IS GETTING
$4.8 MILLION BAILOUT MONEY.
AND AMAZINGLY, THAT’S LESS THEN
UNIVERSITY PRESIDENT SHIRLEY ANN
JACKSON PAYS HERSELF EVERY.
SO PERHAPS SECRETARY DeVOS CAN
DEPOSIT THAT MONEY INTO HER
PERSONAL CHECKING ACCOUNT, MIGHT
AS WELL.
UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN, WHICH IS
A PUBLIC SCHOOL WITH MORE THAN
$12 BILLION IN THE BANK STILL
GOT A $25 MILLION BAILOUT.
THEY PLAN TO SPEND $8 MILLION ON
THE FOOTBALL COACH THIS YEAR.
THEY’RE STILL GOING TO LOSE TO
OHIO STATE, WHICH GOT
$45 MILLION IN BAILOUT MONEY.
THAT SCHOOL PAYS ITS COACHING
STAFF $11 MILLION.
MEANWHILE, THE UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA, SCHOOL FOR KIDS ON
THE HARVARD WAIT-LIST RECEIVED
$9.9 MILLION.
THE PRESIDENT OF U PENN MAKES
NEARLY 3 MILLION.
IT’S ABOUT A THIRD OF THE ENTIRE
BAILOUT.
IF PAYING AMY AT SUCH A
PRIORITY, MAYBE THE SCHOOL COULD
FIND THAT MONEY IN THEIR
$14.7 BILLION ENDOWMENT.
WE COULD GO ON AND ON AND ON, WE
COULD CITE A DOZEN EXAMPLES, IN
FACT, 100 EXAMPLES.
YOUNG PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY ARE
THE POOREST GROUP IN THIS
COUNTRY.
BUT THE SCHOOLS THAT PRETEND TO
EDUCATE THEM ARE THE RICHEST
INSTITUTIONS WE HAVE.
THEY’RE GETTING A BAILOUT THE
YOUNG PEOPLE COULD ONLY DREAM
OF.
WHY?
BECAUSE UNIVERSITIES ARE ONE OF
THE MOST POWERFUL POLITICAL
INTEREST GROUPS IN THE NATION.
AND YOUNG PEOPLE ARE NOT.
AND YOU’RE NOT.
THAT’S WHY THE GOVERNMENT IS
BLOWING BILLIONS GIVING THEM
CASH THEY DON’T NEED AT THE SAME
TIME THEY ARE WONDERING HOW TO
PAY YOUR MORTGAGE.
HARVARD HAS ANNOUNCED IT WILL BE
TAKING BAILOUT FUNDS.
WHY?
BECAUSE THEY SPENT A WEEK BEING
SHAMED IN PUBLIC OVER IT BECAUSE
THEY HAVE A $40 BILLION
ENDOWMENT.
BUT IT SHOULDN’T TAKE SHAME FOR
HARVARD TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
THEY SHOULD BE DECENT ENOUGH TO
DO IT.
THAT’S A PIPE DREAM, THEY ARE
NOT EVEN CLOSE TO DECENT.
BUT IN THE ABSENCE OF THEIR
DECENCY, WE NEED BETTER LAWS.
NOT A SINGLE SENT EVER SHOULD BE